das ist wahrscheinlich wieder so eine
frage die euch alle brennend
interessiert auf jeden fall willkommen
beim ein video und im jahr
mir ist etwas ganz spektakuläres krasse
aufgefallen
deswegen haltet euch fest ich habe schon
vor lange keine frage mehr beantwortet
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ja kommen
ich gebe euch wieder die möglichkeit ihr
habt ihr bei instagram keine ahnung 2500
fragen gestellt oder so ich hab das
schon gelöscht jetzt auf jeden fall habe
ich mir davon ein paar rausgepickt von
euch die beantworte ich jetzt ich hoffe
es gefällt euch wenn ihr bock habt auch
mehr fragen antwortet videos könnt ihr
gerne und nach oben da lassen und ja wir
fangen direkt an mit frage nummer eins
und die kommt von weiss ich gerade
selber nicht aber moment frage nummer
eins kommt von der smi und sie fragt was
würdest du machen wenn du 10.000 euro
hättest gegenfrage was ist wenn ich
10.000 euro würden nicht immer ganz
wichtig geld zu sparen vor allem meinem
alter ist das mega wichtig deswegen
versuche ich auch so im größten teil von
meinem erwerb so was ich so online mache
so halt wirklich zu sparen weil man weiß
ja nie was kommt studiert man macht man
eine ausbildung okay dass er nicht aber
studiert man macht man das und das macht
man nur youtube macht man gar nichts
findet man nichts deswegen ich bin da
schon wirklich ich plane das und
deswegen brauche ich wirklich
ich spare ohne wird die nächste wahl
kommt von http irgendwas zeigt ein 37
foto von seiner galerie jetzt bitte ok
das können wir gern machen so weit ich
musste 10 1 wehrte bei 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
31 35 das ist ein video was ich eher
nicht zeigen möchte kann ich gerne das
38 so bild zeigen das ist uns zwar ist
das hier so schriftzüge bezüglich
unseres mottos für die schule okay ich
kann ich den sound von video zeigen
moment ich kann euch das video leider
nicht zeigen weil sonst wäre eine ganz
bestimmte person ziemlich dollar auf
mich sauer glaub ich und das möchte ich
nun kommen wir auch stand zur nächsten
frage und zwar fragt recovery irgendwas
krieg war dass das ein reh karriere
klappt ja und wie geht's dir eigentlich
du hast dich im letzten video ziemlich
aufgeregt bis ich hoffe dir geht es gut
ich hab das ganze schon sehr mental
mitgenommen
ich bin überhaupt nicht mehr in meinem
leben drin ich weiche gerade total auf
die schiefe bahn ab und bin am boden
zerstört ich hatte ich habe mich gar
nicht so aufgeregt also wenn es noch
nicht gesehen habt schaut euch mein
letztes video an aber das war doch nur
meine meinung mein gott wenn man ich
habe mich nicht aufregen mir geht's
super ich freue mich dass alles so läuft
wie es ist youtube läuft zurzeit heftig
wie haben glaubt in 30 tagen über 50.000
abonnenten dazugewonnen
das ist einfach heftig und deswegen geht
es mir dementsprechend gut im real life
läuft auch alles perfekt ich kann mein
leben schildern ich habe ja keine schule
deswegen mit ihr zusammen man kann sich
trotzdem auf ringer laut schild die
nächste vollkommen von anni hast du in
der schule schon mal etwas richtig
peinliches gemacht ja ich habe überlegt
also ein guter kollege von mir und ich
wir haben so gedacht vielleicht machen
wir daraus mal so ein format wenn die
darauf bock habt dann habt ihr darauf
wartet kurz ich erkläre das kurz und
zwar wir waren alle ganz eng zusammen in
der schule und das sind echt lustige
sachen passiert und vielleicht einfach
so schul stories wo man immer mal wieder
seine schul story erzählt die wirklich
witzig oder bescheuert war oder sonst
was halt wenn ihr darauf gehabt könnte
jetzt gern meine kommentare schreiben
oder ihr lasst einfach nach oben darin
sehe ich das natürlich auch und dann
wird das demnächst auf jeden fall mal
geben die nächste frage kommt von leni
und zwei falls sie hat es für jemals ein
schlimmes beziehungsende das ist
wahrscheinlich wieder so eine frage die
ihr euch alle brennend interessiert auf
jeden fall denkt also das ist ja auch
irgendwie ganz normal wenn man seine
erste freundin hat oder seinen ersten
freund und das dann irgendwann nicht
mehr so läuft beziehungsweise man halt
dann auseinander ist dann ist ja immer
irgendwer von den beiden halt am arsch
oder beide am arsch oder vielleicht auch
ganz wegen keiner aber ja das habe ich
vielleicht auch schon mal so etwas
durchgemacht aber das gehört halt dazu
man lernt im leben vieles neues dazu und
ja so ist das
das ist dann vielleicht monat lang
ziemlich scheiße aber danach geht's auch
wieder komplett bergauf und war bei mir
zumindest so deswegen also alles cool so
wenn irgendwas auseinanderbricht was
auch das herz jetzt sehr poetisch an
wenn irgendwas auseinanderbricht ist es
immer ein gutes zeichen dafür dass was
neues besseres entsteht
und ja so ist es bei mir auch gekommen
deswegen ein tesla mrt ist wirklich so
also das kann man dieses zitat habe ich
irgendwann mal gelesen und es
mut machen wir mit der nächsten frage ob
er eine freundin frage nämlich mit rein
wäre es dir peinlich wenn deine freundin
eine zwillingsschwester hätte und du die
dann beide dann verwechselt und die
andere küsst nee das wäre mir überhaupt
nicht peinlich ich glaube nur dann hätte
ich keine freundin mehr weil das ist ja
das ist schon blöd
selbst wenn eine fast genauso aus wie
deine freunde du bist doch deine
freundin wiedererkennen aber das ist
bestimmt auch schon mal passiert
ich stelle mal vor meine freundin hätte
einfach eine zwillingsschwester die
genauso aussieht wie könnten mich auch
praktisch verarschen
das heißt beide mal sich als einmal
ausgeben egal wir machen weiter mit der
nächsten frage und zwar kommt diese
vornehmlich nie lina und zu hört fragt
sie sammelst du etwas das ist natürlich
auch eine sehr interessante frage
und dazu kann ich sagen ich bin ein sehr
begeisterter sammler und zwar sammle ich
käppis das hört sich jetzt vielleicht
erstmal total doof an
aber es ist einfach so ich habe halt
früher angefangen und habe mich dann
ganz langsam hoch gearbeitet und besitze
derzeit drei käppis nicht sogar vier war
immer einmal habe ich hier ein käppi die
besitze ich schon sehr lange sieht man
auch die war schon 20.000 mal im meer
und ist total durchbringt oder wie das
heißt mit salz des weiteren noch diese
käppi wie setze ich ihr nicht mehr auf
und diese capital setzt sich auch nicht
auch wenn ich eine auf setzte dann ist
das die und ich habe auch noch einen
coolen rucksack rw rinteln ist schuld
sei ich das also der ist cool des von
kohle schöner rucksack habe ich das
jetzt und auch noch ein cooles t shirt
das ist von stay young closing könnt ihr
auch immer abdecken also das würde ich
sagen das war es jetzt erstmal mit
diesem fall antwortet video ihr könnt
auch ganz viele weitere fragen hier
drunter unter das video schreiben dann
kommen als nächstes mal nur meine
youtube von lofer dran weil das sind ja
auch die meisten so in den nächsten
fragen antworte video wenn ihr bock hab
auch nächsten teil der last auf jeden
fall jetzt ein daumen nach oben da würde
mich sehr freuen wenn ihr darauf vor
kraft bei fragen antworten wie es für
mich gehören dazu machen bock hier oben
links hier so weiter abonnieren nicht
vergessen und so warteten schon
dramatisch angemeldet hieß es jetzt
weiter mit meinen letzten video jojo und
wir sehen uns donnerstag wieder da kommt
wahrscheinlich ein video mit meinem
bruder
hat er nicht gehört